the taliban first emerged in the early
1990s pledging to improve security and
fight corruption in afghanistan
fearing its religious traditions were
under threat it also promised to protect
them at any cost enforcing its version
of islamic law
its fighters had been poorly equipped at
times but highly motivated by their
mission to declare what they call an
islamic emirate of afghanistan the
taliban controlled much of the country
from 1996 to 2001. the armed group was
familiar with afghanistan's rugged
terrain and used this knowledge to
outsmart its enemies
when u.s forces overthrew the taliban 20
years ago it managed to survive and
continued to launch attacks against
afghan forces and their western allies
when it was in power members of the
taliban carried out public executions
and amputations commanders banned women
from working girls from going to school
and listening to or playing music
taliban leaders say they recognize the
society has changed and they've promised
to respect people's rights
before we didn't have as much
responsibility as we do today because
now we are all tested by god day by day
we will get involved in the service of
our nation in providing them with
security and hope for their future
largely funded by taxing landowners and
opium the taliban has been welcomed in
some areas of the country while despised
and feared in others
the legitimacy the armed group wanted
was denied time and again but peace
negotiations in qatar's capital gave it
a seat at the table
now with the taliban fully in control of
afghanistan the world is watching and
waiting to see how it will govern the
country and its people osama bin laden